Cotton candy.
Who knew sugar and air could taste so sweet?
Well, a guy named James Morrison,...
...an amateur inventor whose occupation and taste buds didn't exactly align.
He was a dentist.
And during his lifetime,...
...James even became the president of the Tennessee Dental Association.
Don't forget to floss!
But he was also a confectionery enthusiast with a passion for culinary advancement.
He paired with John C. Wharton, an old friend and fellow confectioner.
Together, the two designed and copatented what they called the "electronic candy machine."
The device rapidly spun and melted sugar through small holes...
...until it was fluffy and nearly 70 percent air.
They called the new treat "fairy floss."
Fairy floss was a huge success.
In six months, they sold over 68,000 boxes,...
...grossing in today's money around 440,000 dollars.
But despite the success of their sugar-spun business,...
...Morrison returned to his day job as a dentist.
So, next time the dentist tells you you're eating too many sugary treats,...
...well, blame him.